معنا من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوت هشام
جديد المشهد الميداني والانساني في غزه
هذا
الصباح الجديد هو دائما استمرار القصف
الاسرائيلي القصف الاسرائيلي مستمر لا سما
من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه التي تكثف في هذه
الاثناء قصفها للمناطق الشرقيه الجنوبيه
لخان يونس جنوب قطاع غزه منطقه البطن
السمين جورت اللوت وقيان النجار وهذه
المناطق الثلاثه باتت تتعرض ربما الى
القصف الاعنف القصف الاكثر كثافه القصف
الاكثر حده بعدما عاشت ليله صعبه كما هي
الليالي في الايام السابقه على في ظل
استمرار التوغل الاسرائيلي في تلك المناطق
هذه المناطق تتعرض الى قصف من الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه وجله الاستهدافات هي
استهدافات لمنازل المدنيين الفلسطينيين في
تلك المنطقه ايضا منطقه وسط البلد باتت
تتعرض ايضا هي الاخرى الى قصف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه وهناك غارات متفرقه ما بين
فينه واخرى تشن الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائ
يه غارات وايضا هذه الغارات تستهدف منازل
مدنيه فلسطينيه بالتالي القصف الاسرائيلي
مركز على هذه المنازل مركز على هذه
المناطق في خانيونس وتشهد ايضا منطقه
خانيونس هذه المناطق ومناطق اخرى لا سما
في المناطق الشرقيه اشتباكات عنيفه يسمع
ما بين الفينه والاخرى اصوات انفجارات
عنيفه على ما يبدو انها ناجمه اما عن
القصف الاسرائيلي او حتى عن الاشتباكات
وتفجير المقاومه الفلسطينيه لعبوات ناسفه
واطلاقها لقذائف ياسين باتجاه القوات
الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
الجيش الاسرائيلي من سكان وسط قطاع غزه ان
توجهوا اليها ورغم ذلك يقصف الجيش
الاسرائيلي هذه المنازل المدنيه
الفلسطينيه منطقه منطقه البسطه تعرض فيها
منزل الى قصف اسرائيلي ايضا منطقه البركه
تعرض فيها كذلك منزل الى قصف اسرائيلي
هناك شهداء وجرحى جراء هذا القصف ينقلون
الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى الذي هو الان
يعاني من كارثه صحيه ومن كارثه بسبب نفاذ
الوقود بسبب استمرار العجز في سره والعجز
في الادويه والعجز في المستلزمات وال
الدوائيه والطبيه وايضا الدبابات
الاسرائيليه لا تبعد سوى مئات الامتار عن
هذا المستشفى وبالتالي الاطباء يعيشون تحت
ضغط ويعملون تحت ضغط كبير في ظل استمرارهم
واصرارهم على الاستمرار في تقديم هذه
الرعايه الصحيه وان كانت رعايه صحيه صعبه
ورعايه صحيه منخفضه للغايه في ظل هذا
النقص الحاد في كل ما يلزم من اجل تطبيب
هؤلاء الجرحى وهؤلاء هؤلاء المصابين وايضا
ه هؤلاء المرضى الذين يفقدون حياتهم بسبب
عدم قدرتهم وخطوره المكان الذي يتواجد فيه
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى بفعل تواجد الدبابات
الاسرائيليه على بعد مئات الامتار ايضا
المناطق منطقه مخيم المغازي قصفت فيها
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه عده منازل
عده احياء بل مربعات سكنيه دمرتها وسوتها
بالارض وهناك عشرات من الشهداء نحو 20
شهيد من عائله درويش التي قصف الجيش
الاسرائيلي منزلهم وهو المنزل الذي
استطعنا مع عرفت انه قصف لكن هناك العشرات
من المنازل دمرت العشرات من المنازل تضررت
وقصفت الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه ولكن
هذه العائله كانت تتواجد في هذا المنزل
عند دوار صدقي في مخيم المغازي دمرت
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه هذا المنزل
سوته بالارض ولم تستطع سيارات الاسعاف ولا
سيارات الدفاع المدني الوصول اليه بسبب
استمرار اطلاق النار على هذه السيارات
ومنع الجيش الاسرائيلي وصول هذه الطواقم
الى مخيم المغازي لا سيما في ظل استمرار
القصف في ظل استمرار ايضا طائرات تحليق
طائرات كواد كابتر اسرائيليه تطلق النار
على هؤلاء وع على هذه الطواقم وعلى هؤلاء
ضباط الاسعاف وطواقم الدفاع المدني الذين
يحاولون الوصول من دير البلح الى مخيم
المغازي او حتى الى مخيم البريج الذي ما
زال ايضا يعاني من جراء استمرار القصف
الاسرائيلي ومن جراء منع هذه الطواقم من
الوصول اليه دير البلح تقع في غرب شارع
صلاح الدين و وايضا مخيم المغازي ومخيم
البريج في المنطقه الشرقيه وبالتالي
استمرار هذا المنع من دخول حتى شارع صلاح
الدين من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي هشام زقوت
مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا من رفح شكرا جزيلا
لك